when was the production for california
christmas
so we started filming um i'm trying to
remember the exact date but it was in
july
of 2020 july of 2020 yeah so it was a
very
quick turnaround from filming to release
um uh it was it was uh
we were working 24 7 to try and get it
finished through post and delivered
because we had to deliver
in i think late october um
was was the requirement for delivery if
it was gonna air in in december
so um uh it was a very very fast
turnaround
so but yeah we started filming in in
january
and uh of course we had to get
everything approved through sag and all
of that with the coveted protocols and
and all of that and assuming it was
filmed in california correct
yes it was filmed in california yeah
yeah what were the protocols oh sorry oh
yeah i was just gonna say up in northern
california petaluma
and sonoma and the surrounding areas is
where we filmed
it was beautiful i felt so lucky and
blessed that number one i was getting to
work
during this time because there's so many
people who can't work
um and that was certainly the case
before i got to film this i hadn't been
able to do any physical production
obviously for months and months oh
really sorry to interrupt but you sat
you were at home
probably yeah i was able to do some
other work and i had post work to do and
things like that so
i still was keeping myself busy but um
yeah not
not going and physically filming
anything
so i felt very lucky to be able to do
that and yes we had to have a very
extensive plan
number one just to show to sag and
daniel aspermante who was one of the
producers on it
he put together this very detailed
highly detailed
plan of how we would shoot it how we
would keep everybody safe
and a very impressive plan that he put
together
and because the movie is a little bit
more self-contained
it focuses on these two actors who
happen to be married in real life
that helped with you know certainly
getting things approved when they got
approved because we were
like i mentioned before one of the first
features to to film
since this whole thing kind of started
since you know shutdowns happened
and so um uh but yeah it was very
interesting it was a whole different
world
uh as far as filming goes um
with the covid protocols number one we
were tested like every other day
um onset the good old nose swabs
and uh we had more medics on set
um and also were temperature checked
when we arrived we were temperature
checked before we left every night
um just highly diligent we wore face
masks of course
um if we were in close proximity with
the actors we'd also have the shields so
we'd have mask and shield on
and to that effect nobody was really
allowed to go
get close to the actors while they were
on set other than the camera the the
camera operators and or dp
and myself the director and maybe the ad
first ad
were really the only people that could
get in close proximity with the actors
when they didn't have their masks on
so we had to follow those rules there
was also zones
so uh you know only a certain amount of
people total
could be in any zone at one given time
so
obviously set itself or base camp would
be the hottest zone that's where the
most people would be
but we tried to keep that all separate
and on top of all of this we had a
coveted officer so we had somebody on
set who was overseeing this stuff
and making sure we were keeping socially
distant um
and that we had our masks up they don't
fall down over our nose and
you know you got a bunch of people with
their noses out he was he's on it
uh matt a wonderful gentleman who was
our covet officer
um he was overseeing all of that and
making sure
uh that we were following all the rules
and
um and he actually did it in a very
pleasant way it's not like he he's
yelling at people
hey your mask is down now he's very very
kind
about it but he's very diligent as well
he's on top of it i mean
you really you know um and then
the other thing that i forgot to mention
is when the actors are on set
no none of the other departments can
come and work with them on set even
including wardrobe and makeup
they would have to leave set first to be
able to be checked like outside
things like that as well like when we're
indoors they have to have all the doors
open
you know it's like all of those things
uh to be
um very diligent with that stuff and
then like let's say we need to adjust a
light
well the actors would have to step
offset first be cleared
then the electricians can come in
the the uh and grip department can come
in and they can fix a light or whatever
but the really cool thing that brad
rushing our dp
thought about in all of this and i
thought it was genius
was they he decided
to try and light from outside as much as
possible
so bringing in light sources from
outside whether it's backlighting the
actor
from like you know it's sunlight or
artificial sunlight coming through a
window
or however it was designed he tried to
design a lot of it
uh coming from outside and the lights
that were inside
were remote so we had our
gaffers in our lighting department they
could adjust everything
like on ipads and things like that they
were able to dim and do different things
they were able to do a lot without
needing to physically go on set
and have to remove the actors because
that of course all takes extra time
so i thought that was pretty genius to
to approach it that way
um and help us keep our keep our
schedules you know
did did you notice that you would tend
to shoot outside more or no i was just
wondering if that was part of that was
part of the design yeah
we did think about that early on with
these protocols try and limit
the amount of scenes that need to be
shot indoors
and again you know trying to keep it
more open
space and when we did go into like a
bedroom or something like that
the crew became very minimal so uh
again with the covet officer we worked
with him to figure out well how many
people can be upstairs safely
and it wasn't about like how many people
you know can we get in we want to get in
as many as we can
there's literally about like what is a
real safe you know like what's the real
number
can we only have five people up here you
can have two people in that room and you
can have three people in this room you
know what i mean so we kind of became
that dance
and everybody else has to stay
downstairs or outside you know so it was
that thing so there was a lot of
things to juggle that you don't normally
have to yes they add time
the testing adds time to your like
actually takes away time from your shoot
day
um so you have to account for all of
those things but
what i will say is it sounds daunting it
sounds like oh this isn't gonna work
uh but what i will say is that the the
crew
and the new people the the the people
dealing with the covet testing and all
of that
we all got into a rhythm you know first
couple days obviously it's rougher
but we all got into a rhythm and by the
end we were all firing on all cylinders
and
you know came everybody came and got
their tests that you know it just
just you know we came together and we
made it happen um
and uh and everybody worked really hard
you had to work hard because the other
the other thing about it is we had less
crew because
you can't have too many people so that
can put strain on the different
departments like now they have one less
or two less people than they normally
have
so again luckily we have a team of
people that really
aren't afraid of hard work and they put
in the hard work and they all deserve
all the accolades they can get because
they really do put in
a tremendous amount of work and that's
why i keep working with the same team
i think because we share that common
goal of you know all trying to make
something as good as we can especially
whether it's limited resources or time
or
but they all just work really really
hard and and
i think we're able to accomplish really
great things even
in the you know
constraints of working during this time
is the covet officer someone you're
hiring
off mandy or one of these sites or is
this someone from the state
that's a great question i not qualified
to answer i don't know
um producers they handled all of that
it is definitely somebody who's
certified within that you know i don't
even know all the certifications but
they're um
yeah again i don't really know but i
know that they are very they're
certified they're they're up with all
the testing like the latest
like that when we were filming the tests
were changing and we had always the
latest and greatest the best or whatever
it was
we started when we first showed up we
were doing blood tests
and then it became uh we were doing the
finger prick stuff
at the beginning and then that morphed
into just doing the nose swabs and then
there was different levels of nose swabs
and
you know like it was very interesting
but they're always at the like forefront
of whatever it is that's going to be the
best
have the highest accuracy you know all
those things
um and yeah it was very
very interesting and and that whole team
so not just himself but there's a whole
team behind it they all were wonderful
and and obviously uh their job was to
try and keep us safe
um and you know luckily they did
what about crew feed how's that done
because you know normally it's going to
be
like a buffet style that that all
changed too yeah so
uh everything is kind of individually
packaged so
and we have caterers and stuff like that
that that
craft services was very definitely very
different so everything has to be
individually wrapped
uh you're not you can't go through and
thumb through and touch a bunch of stuff
you have to
figure out what you're gonna choose that
bag of fritos now that
you touch that bag at your bag you know
that kind of thing um
but the probably the biggest bummer is
like i always like to have like fresh
fruit and stuff like that i can't really
do that
with these protocols so unfortunately
unless you brought it your own in your
own bag you know which i did i brought
bananas and apples
of myself um but uh
yeah that was very different and again
the lunches are very different
you could only have everybody was spaced
out like this
you know the seating area can't have
everybody bunched in and always outside
basically um and um
but yeah the the lunches uh
the meals were all just kind of like in
their own little kind of package
you know individual portions and
packaged and
it was fine it you know it was uh
uh just became you know kind of
standard after the first week everybody
was used to it
what was the shooting schedule uh so the
shooting schedule was
um we usually do like five on two off
type of thing and i think we had one six
day
uh maybe we had two really it was it was
a pretty
short schedule that's the other i think
reason why we got approved so early on
is it's a limited amount of days so
that's another thing that they were
looking for like
you know what's the shortest amount of
time you can film this in
to to limit uh you know uh
you know risk of somebody getting
infected so um
i think we had about 15 days uh for this
shoot
all in like all together which is not a
lot of time
to film a movie but again like i said we
have a
great crew that helps us um accomplish
those goals
what was the last day of shooting and
then i'm not sure again what the day for
deliverables was i think in october gosh
i have to look when the
when the last day of shooting was um i
think we were just about
um just rolled over into august or just
right before
um august i can't remember exactly the
date
but yeah from that time to getting it
delivered
you know was was we usually have twice
that amount of time
to get it done however many months that
is what is that uh
basically the end of october is when we
had to deliver
um if my memory is serving me correctly
and so not only so the good thing was
that
the editor had started the process while
we were filming so
as we were still filming as they got
footage delivered to them
on hard drives through the mail or
couriers
they would get the footage brett hedlin
was the the editor
he would get it and then process it and
then start cutting the scenes
so um that was all happening
you know it's offset by obviously a few
days
um but then once he gets rolling he's
just you know
getting the new footage and continuing
to try and put the pieces together
and by the time we finish shooting it
wasn't far
after that that we had the first rough
cut um
and so and then i once i was finished
filming i got to look at the cuts and
start and we break it up in reels so i
started reviewing
the reels giving my notes figuring out
what tweaks we can do
or if we're missing a piece you know how
we're gonna solve that and
um so from the editing just getting the
the picture cut
then to the sound design to the score
i mean uh jamie christopherson who
did our score he had such a small amount
of time to do the score
i was blown away with the speed at which
he
was able to do it and we had several
original songs in there
that he produced along with caitlyn
epperly
who is in the movie but she also sings
several original songs for it
and while we were filming
he had to be helping create those like
rough versions for her to perform
and lip-sync live to uh while we were
filming it
but that meant those songs had to be
done and so
that whole decision that we're gonna do
these original songs
and you know from that time to filming
those actual scenes was so short amount
of time i was blown away he was able to
do it
and of course they were rough versions
of the song but they still sounded
fantastic
and of course they went in they did they
even re-recorded some of the vocals and
did things after the fact but to to get
that and we had to have her go and
record
her audio for it and so is this this
pretty
amazing dance that happened but but it
all worked out beautifully
and
then getting people in adr which was
really interesting because
um we couldn't bring everybody in like
like even for myself i didn't go into
the studio for the adr
i did it from home and so did a lot of
our actors they didn't go to the studio
either they were
either abroad or some of them were in
their hotel rooms
doing adr for us you know we'd either
send a microphone or
or you know somehow get it that way and
uh
it was really really interesting i'd
never experienced anything like that but
from from doing it like that all remote
to even the color correction sessions
remotely all doing it over zoom
and now we've all got a much shorter
time to do it
it was uh incredibly challenging but
again
everybody just rose to the challenge and
i think that's a lot of
of you know the positive stories out of
that i've seen as people rising to
challenges and it's really
to me it's inspirational obviously i try
and look at the glass half
full versus empty that's just my
personality but
um i really have seen some amazing
things come out of this year of such
tragedy and
obviously so many uh hardships and
so much that has gone wrong in this year
i've
seen how people have risen to that
challenge and just it's been
inspirational in that respect do you
think it reminds you
of of how you do things because i could
see you always wanting to problem solve
and fix it and yeah and being successful
at that yeah i think
there's probably at some level there
there is me seeing
uh you know people maybe problem solve
in in the way that makes sense to me so
maybe maybe that's what uh
uh attracts me to to seeing that but um
uh yeah i certainly think my uh
again i go back to my martial arts i
think
martial arts itself at least what i have
been able
to study and the teachers that i've been
lucky enough to to train under
is it's all about problem solving so it
that's 100
of what it is um you know whether you're
fighting an opponent or not
or nothing confrontational because
martial arts
again from what the way i've been taught
is it goes much beyond combat
there there is that aspect of it there
is self-defense there is
the sport element of it but beyond that
it's it's kind of philosophy and problem
solving
and it helps you in all walks of life
and i think it certainly has helped me
in
filmmaking sean how do you feel about
you
filmed this movie in july of 2020
it's now mid-december 2020 and today
it's the first day it's on netflix
um i have to say it's actually a really
good feeling um
because a lot of times in filmmaking
as you guys probably well know it can
take a long time from inception
to to release in some cases years
and that's certainly been the case for a
lot of my movies
some of them are three plus years before
they end up
coming out and even big blockbuster
movies they have similar tales some of
them are
three plus years um other movies kind of
get shelved for a while it could be five
years before they come out
so to have something
that you work on within the same year
and i mean even like
basically less than six months uh
kind of go from inception to release it
feels great
it's really nice to see something uh and
and hopefully get a good response and
what just today it's released but i've
already gotten
really really nice and sweet responses
and and uh
that's just a an amazing feeling and uh
a feeling that i hope any creator gets
to experience at some point
um because i also remember
every inch of the set and every second
every minute of of that production
because it's still so fresh in my brain
and to go from that to
seeing people's reactions to it this
quickly it's a it's a
it's kind of you know endorphin inducing
feeling it feels really wonderful i
had a great morning waking up to getting
some of those messages and
um with some of the other movies it's
been like three years
it's really hard to remember you know i
remember certain moments but it's
obviously not the same thing it's it's
been a long time
uh since uh you know working on those
projects
you